[Música]
me presento julio morán
estoy completamente nerviosa estar acá
pero a la vez estoy contento y muy
orgulloso estar en esta linda tierra por
muchas razones que le voy a mencionar 3
la primera estoy en la tierra del mocho
la segunda tiene una gastronomía
increíble increíble
y la tercera
soy 100% italiano como decimos acá
chiclayano de pura cepa
bueno para empezar
quiero que sepan que soy chef
y me encanta comer encanta pero no
siempre fue así
te voy a contar una historia
de repente a muchos les ha pasado o le
sigue pasando
cuando era niño y tenía un plato de
verduras frente a mí
también al costado tenía los ojos de mi
madre y en su mano una cuchara de palo
ella hacía todo eso para que yo coma
señores aunque les parezca gracioso
eso era nutrición
y ahorita que heidi no está
a mí me regalaron mi cocina de chiquito
no sé
me hizo chef sin goma lamentablemente o
nos es implementable mente pero me gusta
comer y cocino muy bien
y gracias a ellas a nuestras madres
ingerimos comida casera hecha con amor
con los mejores insumos que no la
naturales
en tema
que ellas
se iban a los mercados y los cogían al
detalle a diario
pero muchos de nosotros nos hemos
olvidado de la importancia de esta
comida
tal vez porque el trabajo no nos da el
tiempo o de repente el tiempo utilizado
para cosas más importantes
y porque también tenemos a la tecnología
en nuestro lado
sin duda es más fácil un celular
que una olla
les puedo decir que trabajaba en todas
las áreas de una cocina
he sido lavaplatos elfidio cocinero he
sido jefe gerente alimentos y bebidas
embajador de la cocina peruana
en fin
a lo largo de mi vida he viajado por
muchos lugares
y ha ido comiendo toda clase de comida
buen y mal
y el detalle nunca fui consciente de lo
que cada cosa que ingería significaba
para mi cuerpo
y pasó esto
hace un año y medio
estando a punto de regresar de
vacaciones a la ciudad de iquitos donde
trabajo actualmente trabajo
me dio un dolor de cabeza extraño y
fuerte
que pensé que era la resaca del día
anterior pero lamentablemente recordé
que había tomado una limonada
era raro no
y luego
perdón luego sentí mareos
y claro con mis 150 kilos que tenía en
ese entonces
no era raro pensar colesterol
triglicéridos
pero se me nubló la vista
y algo me decía que esto no era normal
sus emergencias y al cabo de unas horas
el diagnóstico fue un tumor cerebral
sí
treinta días después operado y sin tumor
el diagnóstico de patología salió cáncer
así es señores
yo nací virgo pero por circunstancias de
la vida me morí cáncer
e
el tema
este es un poquito fuerte como para mí
no tanto por el tema que me da mi
descanso sino lo que le hizo mi familia
y que lo que le hace
esta noticia
había cambiado había había puesto a leer
también mi conciencia
así que
manos a la obra
revise todo aquello que pueda aportar a
mi recuperación y la comida no sólo no
fue la excepción sino es una pieza
fundamental
una pieza muy fundamental
es
empecé
a informarme un poco más obviamente el
ser chef no es no es solamente cocinar
comer probar
en realidad es ver el producto desde
dónde vienes cómo se puede procesar
porque tiene este color porque debe
conservar este color porque debe ser
crocante porque no porque sí por qué no
bueno
decidí
cambiar mi
mi paradigma mi paradigma de cocina
luego de esto
de todo esto amigos
chiclayanos
y amigos de cocina y amigos de mundo me
ayudaron mucho en este tema
bueno
retomando el tema
la comida es muy importante en este caso
y si no sabemos balancear la
nos puede ir mal
cosa que
ahora en esta época
entre otras cosas esta palabrita que se
está haciendo muy común en la sociedad
es 3
el estrés que genera
ansiedad estrés más ansiedad hambre
y este tipo de hambre
no busca calidad
sino obviamente cantidad
se preguntarán por qué les digo esto
pues
no fue fácil si una persona
así
que comen a diario
todos los platos que puedan haber de un
restaurante porque les comento
como chef yo cantaba mañana y tarde y
noche todos los platos que serían al
salón
tenía que verlo porque porque mi nombre
iba por ahí en ese plato yo en calidad
de chef les garantizo
que los ricos
para que sea rico en toda la extensión
de la palabra tiene que ser sano
bueno
tomemos conciencia
y compartamos lo con nuestro entorno
cada alimento que ingerimos cada
alimento que ingerimos me aporta algo
nuestro cuerpo por ejemplo
una naranja es un ejemplo una naranja
nos puede comer una naranja
tu cuerpo recibe energía
to come to yo tu cuerpo recibe
equilibrio tú con mezquino a tu cuerpo
recibo armonía
tú comes menestra tu cuerpo recibe
fuerza
yo decidí hace un año
es lo que recibe en mi cuerpo
pues
gracias a ello
gracias a la alimentación
cada día me siento mejor
hago ejercicio diario no se nota mucho
que si bien se han conocido antes si
hubiesen conocido antes yo estaba en 123
kilos
ahora estoy en un 98
y gracias a eso empecé a bajar de peso
gracias a la alimentación voy a cambiar
todo esto me siento mucho mejor
me siento mucho mejor
eso fue hace un año y medio
recupere mi trabajo en iquitos donde
actualmente radicó
empecé averiguar un poco más de la
naturaleza conocí nativos y los nativos
se alimentan de puro yuca al millón de
la yuca las harinas
se alimentan muy bien
empecé a estudiar un poquito más de las
hierbas de los frutos empecé a conocer
un poquito más mi cuerpo cómo reacciona
con cada alimento
y les digo
y la alimentación
de repente no es primordial en una salud
tarde tendría les puedo estar diciendo
otras cosas de repente el doctor te
puede decir otra cosa como a mí me dicen
a ti te hemos operado de la cabeza no el
estómago
come lo que quieras
pero yo me limito un poco
entiendo un poquito mío
y mi cuerpo
de civil
y cambiar todo
por mi familia
por mi hija
es la razón de mi existir
por mis amigos que tanto han hecho por
mí cuando yo estuve y echado postrado
con un ciempiés acá
porque era enorme la cicatriz
esto fue hace un año es unánime
le agradezco mucho a esa gente que se
preocupó bastante por mí
en el río
si nos alimentamos bien
comemos fuerza vitalidad
energía equilibrio
no habrá
enfermedad alguna contra la que no
podamos luchar y ganar
mis días
ahora empiezan
y terminan con mucha fuerza y bienestar
y he vuelto a trabajar en lo que más me
gusta la cocina seis días a la semana
pero obviamente con otra mirada
con otra mirada de lo que es la
gastronomía
le agradezco a la vida por un día más en
pie
y el equilibrio que puedo tener yo
mentalidad cuerpo es muy importante
demasiado importante
bueno
le agradezco mucho repito le agradezco
mucho la vida
a mi familias le agradezco bastante
el tema de que esta universidad y aparte
por mi hijo
si ustedes
estoy acá parado para poder darles esta
experiencia y espero pueda entenderme un
poco y marque un poquito en ustedes lo
que es la alimentación
y por cualquier persona que está acá y
ven minis una experiencia
veo una luz en la oscuridad
si es así atrapen la y hagan la suya
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]